JAMES DONG: Good afternoon.
My name is James Dong.
I'm working on the Android
Media team.
Today, I'm here to present you
set of new low-level media
APIs we published in Android
Jellybean release.
So this set of low-level media
APIs allows the Java
applications to directly access
the low-level decoding,
and the encoding capabilities of
the media codecs available
on a specific Android device.
We use this set of new
low-level media APIs.
As Java developers, you are
given much more flexibility
and a finer granularity control
on how your media
application behaves.
Today, my talk is partitioned
into two parts.
In the first a part, I will
briefly talk about the
existing Android media
architecture and the existing
high level media APIs prior
to Jellybean release.
In the second part, I will focus
on my talk on the new
low level media APIs
we published
in Jellybean release.
So let's start off with the
brief introduction to the
media framework architecture.
Android power the devices.
Typically, you see many media
rated applications, such as
Camera, Music app,
Gallery, YouTube,
movie player, et cetera.
All of these applications
basically use the same
architecture.
Each application is partitioned
into two separate
address spaces, the application
process and the
media server process.
The communication between the
application process and the
MediaServer process is using the
Android remote procedure
call, or Binder call.
In the MediaServer process, a
set of commonly used media
services, such as the playback,
recording, audio
routing, are provided.
The MediaServer process then
talks to the drivers in a
kernel through a hardware
abstract layer.
For decoding and the encoding
purpose, the hardware
abstraction layer is the OpenMAX
integration layer.
You can find out a detailed
reference UI, basically, at
the end of my slides if
you want to find out
details about OpenMAX.
So prior to Jellybean release,
we already have a set of
high-level media APIs.
With these high-level media
APIs, you are able to write
applications quickly.
On this slide, I show you a
really simple example on how
to write a playback, or
streaming application using a
high-level media API, which is
the MediaPlayer.Java class.
As this point, I assume you
are pretty familiar with
MediaPlayer.Java class.
And I will quickly
walk through the
example on this slide.
First, what you need to do is
to create a media player
object, and then set its data
source by passing it a URL.
The URL can be a local file on
your Android device, or it can
be pointing to a media data
source that is located on a
remote server.
So after you config the media
player object, then you can
send the prepare message to
the media object, which
basically will validate the data
sources, see whether this
file format is supported
by the parser.
And if the parsing succeeded,
then you can use the common
set of media controls like
start, pause, and to control
the payback or streaming.
You can also jump to a specific
time position by
calling seekTo if the data
source is seekable.
So it depends on the interaction
between users and
the application.
This process may be iterated
multiple times.
And then, at the end of a
playback session, you want to
terminate the playback session
by calling stop.
Immediately after the
termination for playback
session, you want to release
all of the associated
resources with media player
object by calling release.
So as you can see from this
extremely simplified example,
you do not need to write
too many lines of code.
And it provides a high
abstraction level on how you
can control a media playback
or streaming application.
So with these existing
high-level media APIs prior to
Jellybean release, we are able
to meet the needs of mostly
commonly used media application
use cases.
And we are able to support a
commonly used file formats.
In addition, we are able to
support most commonly used
streaming format, a protocol
like HTTP, RTSP, [INAUDIBLE].
However, as a powered Java
developer, you are often given
the challenge to do more.
So what if you are given a task
to write an application
to support a file format that
is not yet supported by the
Android platform?
What if you are given a task
to write a streaming
application to use a streaming
protocol that is not yet
supported by the Android
platform?
What if you want to do some
image processing on the output
of the decoder, and then you
send the [INAUDIBLE]
for rendering?
So what if after the image
processing, you want to send
the output to be used as an
input to an encoder, and then
encode it and then streaming
the result out?
For these kinds of advanced
challenges, with the existing
high-level media APIs, to
be honest, you probably
cannot do too much.
So that's why we published a
set of new low-level media
APIs in Jellybean release
to address this set of
challenges.
So this new set of low-level
media APIs mainly consist of
three parts.
The first part is
a file parser.
Basically, it's a new class
called MediaExtractor.
It allows you to parse all the
currently supported file
formats on Android platform.
The second part of the new
low-level API is the ability
to query the capabilities of the
media codecs available on
an Android device.
Why you need this capability is
you need to find out what
are the available codecs so
that you can create the
specific media codec to do
decoding and encoding directly
from your application process.
So that's why you need the third
part of the API, which
is the MediaCodec.Javaclass.
So this class provide the direct
access of decoding and
the encoding functions of the
available media codecs on an
Android device.
So I will start with the first
part, the file parser.
Before I want to talk about the
details of the APIs in the
MediaExtractor class, a basic
understanding of a general
file structure for a typical
media data source might help.
So a typical media data source
consists of one or more
elementary streams, which
we call tracks.
Each track then belongs to a
specific type, like audio or
video or text.
So for each specific track, it
has one or more sample datas
associated with it.
For each sample data, it can be
a decoder specific data, or
it can be the actual compressed
access unit of
audio frame, or video frame.
So it can has data itself, and
it also provides information
about the media data, such as
the time stamp you need to
present the data.
And usually, for video purpose,
it will also tell you
whether the current sample
is a sync frame.
So with this basic understanding
of the file
structure of a typical media
source, then I will to
introduce you the first you
low-level media API, which is
MediaExtractor.
So if you look at the
MediaExtractor, we provide a
defaulting constructor for you
to create an instance of a
MediaExtractor.
And then, you can use a set of
data source, which I assume
you are pretty familiar with a
set of data source methods
similar to what media
player has to
configure your data source.
So once the data source is
configured, you can find out
the total number of available
tracks from your data source
by calling getTrackCount.
And then, for each individual
track count, you can find of
detailed format about it by
calling getTrackFormat.
So getTrackFormat will return
you a object of media format,
which is another API we released
in Android Jellybean.
I'll talk about media format
in the next slide.
So in order to use the parser,
then you need to select a
specific media track to use,
to read the data from.
In order to do that, you
can call selectTrack.
So for instance, a media data
source may have multiple audio
tracks for different
languages.
So you want to select a specific
language for your
application to use.
Then you can use selectTrack.
You can also deselect this track
so that you won't pass
data from this specific
media track.
You can also make do a random
seek within the data source by
calling seekTo, which
takes two arguments.
First one is the time position
you want to seek to.
The second argument is basically
the seek mode.
So for example, if you want to
seek to a sync frame, or you
want to seek to a time position
that is after but
closer to a sync frame.
So there are a number of seek
modes you can use to affect
the behavior, how you seek to
inside the data source.
If you don't want to do a random
seek, you just want to
move to next sample position,
you can just simply call
advance, which will move to the
next sample sequentially.
So once you reach a specific
time position and then you can
read media data or decoder
specific information data
using readSampleData message.
So this is readSampleData
message takes two arguments.
The first one is the buffer
that you want to read the
sample data into.
The second argument, basically,
provide an offset
that you'll start to
put your data in.
It also returns an integer to
indicate whether your read is
successful, or whether
it reaches the end
of your data source.
So if it's non-active value,
it indicates the read is
successful.
If it is an active value, that
indicates the read reaches the
end of a stream.
So for each example, as I just
mentioned in the previous
slide, you can find a bunch
of metadata associated.
So one of the important pieces
of information is the
presentation time.
So in order to find the
presentation time for that
sample, you can call
getSampleTime.
Reach will return the
presentation time in
microseconds.
And you can also find out the
flags associated with this
particular sample, such as
whether this sample is a sync
frame, whether the sample is
decoder specific information.
If your data source is not a
local file source, then you
need to cache the data.
So in order to find out how many
cached data in a RAM, or
in a memory, you can use
getCachedDuration to find out
how much amount of data actually
cached in memory.
And you can also use
hasCacheReachedEndOfStream to
find out whether the data
cached in memory already
reached the end of
a stream or not.
As I mentioned a little bit
earlier, in order to find out
details about a specific media
track, you need to use a new
class called MediaFormat.
MediaFormat.Javaclass basically
encapsulate a set of
key value pairs.
And in addition to that, it also
makes available a bunch
of status in the getter's
message, so that you can find
out the value or modify
the value associated
with a given key.
For example, if you want to
find out an audio track's
number of audio channels, you
can just provide a key channel
count to find out the value
about the number of channels.
So to give you an example on
how these two API works, I
will show you two examples.
The first example basically
shows you a typically use of
the MediaExtractor
API we provided.
So first off, you need to
create a MediaExtractor
instance by calling its
default constructor.
And then, just like your media
player object, you'll set its
data source.
So once its data source is set,
and then you can find the
total available tracks from that
data source by calling
getTrackCount.
So by iterate through all the
available tracks, so you can
find out the media track you are
interested in and then you
select that specific media track
by calling selectTrack.
So once you select the
particular media track you are
interested in, then you are able
to read data from that
track by calling
readSampleData.
So readSampleData basically will
read the sample the give
time position into the
buffer it provided.
If the readSampleData returns
a negative value, that means
you already reached
the end of stream.
If it is a positive number,
that means the read is
successful.
And in addition to the media
data, you can find out it's
metadata, like its presentation
time, sample
time, and flags associated
with the sample.
And you can decide whether you
want to move to the next
sample by calling
advance message.
Or you want to jump to a
random time position by
calling seekTo.
So this process can
iterate until you
reach the end of stream.
Once you're done with the
MediaExtractor, then you just
call release message to release
all the resources
associated with this object.
So how to find out a media track
that you are interested
in, you'll need to know the
detail to track information.
That's why you need to use
this MediaFormat class.
So with this MediaFormat class,
you can find out the
mime stream for a specific
media track.
And from the mime stream, you
are able to tell whether this
media track is audio or video,
or any other media type.
And if it is audio, you can find
out number of channels,
sample rate, by using a getter
message, as I mentioned.
If it's video, you can use
the getter message, like
getInteger, to find out
the video resolution.
So the use for MediaFormat
class is really
straightforward.
I want to emphasize the file
parser MediaExtractor class
basically supports all the
existing formats currently we
are supporting on Android
platform.
However, if you ask to support
a file format that is not
currently supported, you
need to implement
your own file parser.
So this MediaExtractor basically
just provides you an
example of how you can implement
your own media
extractor to support a new file
format that is not supported.
So that's the first part of
the low-level media API.
Now, let me move on to the
second part of the media API.
Basically, it's the ability to
query the capabilities of
media codecs available
on an Android device.
So we published two new APIs,
MediaCodecList and
MediaCodeInfo.
So let me show you how
these two API works.
For MediaCodecList,
it's very simple.
There are only two public
APIs you can call.
The first one lets you'll find
out the total number of
available codec count on
an Android device.
The first one, basically,
is getCodecCount method.
The second method is
getCodecInfoAt message, which
allows you to find out the
detail capabilities of a
specific MediaCodec.
So you need to use the new API,
MediaCodecInfo, in order
to find out details,
capabilities of a MediaCodec.
So the MediaCodecInfo class will
tell you what's the codec
name for this MediaCodec,
whether it is a
decoder or an encoder.
And you can also find out the
number of MIME types that this
specific MediaCodec supports.
So just for your information,
the same MediaCodec may be
able to support multiple
MIME types.
So that's why the
getSupportedTypes returns a
rate of stream.
So it basically tells
you all the MIME
types it will support.
By iterating through the
supported types, you are able
to find out the capabilities for
a specific MIME type for
this given MediaCodec.
So you need this inner class
called CodecCapabilities in
order to find out the
specific capability.
So what are the capabilities
exposed through this API?
Basically, two pieces
of information.
The first one is a list of
color formats that is
supported by this codec.
The second piece of information,
basically, is a
list of profiles and levels
supported by this MediaCodec.
So to give you an example on
how this MediaCodecList and
MediaCodecInfo works, here
is a very simple example.
OK, so first you call
MediaCodecList.getCodecCount
to find out all the available
codecs on a specific device.
So once you have the count, then
you can iterate through
it by calling getCodecInfoAt
to find out the detailed
compatibility of a specific
MediaCodec.
So this method returns you an
object of MediaCodecInfo.
So using that info object, you
can find out whether this
codec is encoder or decoder.
And you can find out all the
MIME types it supports by
calling getSupportedTypes.
With the rate of supported
types, then you can iterate
through all of them and find
out the capability for each
MIME type that this media
codec can do.
So in this particular example, I
would like to find out which
MediaCodec is capable of
decoding an AVC video that is
encoded in high profile,
level 4.0.
So how to find out that.
And first, you can check the
type, see whether the MIME
type supported by this
MediaCodec is AVC.
So basically, just check the
type against video slash AVC.
You can find out whether this
MediaCodec is support AVC.
So if this video codec is
support AVC, then you can find
out the capabilities
of this MediaCodec.
So there are two pieces
of information,
as I mentioned earlier.
One is that the list of
output color format.
And the second one is the
list of profiles and
levels getting exposed.
So you can just iterate through
the list of profiles
and the levels exposed by the
capability object, and then
compel to see whether this
MediaCodec is supporting high
profile level four.
So the use of this
MediaCodecList, and the
MediaCodecInfo API is pretty
much straightforward.
Behind a theme how
this API works.
For each Jellybean Android
device, we require a registry
XML file to be put on the
device, which actually tells
you all the available
Media Codecs.
So on this slide, I show you
a simple example of this
media_codecs.xml file.
So in this XML file, you can
see there are two lists of
Media Codecs.
One list is for encoder.
The second list is
for decoder.
Regardless of whether it is
a decoder instance, or an
encoder instance, each of
MediaCodec entry has a single
attribute for name.
So this name will tell you the
MediaCodec name that you got
from MediaCodecInfo class.
So that's the getName method.
It will return you the name
attribute of the MediaCodec.
Any media codec, actually,
with the same name, can
support multiple MIME types.
So if you have multiple MIME
type support for a single
MediaCodec, you can have
multiple attributes for type.
That's why if you look at
MediaCodecInfo class, it has a
method called getSupportedTypes,
so which
will return all the MIME types
that you like available in
this media_codecs.xml file for
a specific MediaCodec entry.
So that MediaCodecList and
MediaCodecInfo classes
addresses the need, and what are
the available codecs own
the specific Android device.
So once you know the available
codecs, you can use a media
codec class to create an
instance of that codec to
directly access the low-level
decoding or encoding
capabilities.
So how to do that.
First, let me show you the
API available in this
MediaCodec.Java class.
The three methods in this class
allows you to create a
MediaCodec.
So a media codec can be created
either by the MIME
type it supports, or if you know
the specific name for the
MediaCodec, you can just
pass the name.
You can create a decoding
instance, or an encoding
instance this way.
Once you have a MediaCodec
instance, then you need to
configure this MediaCodec for
decoding or encoding purpose
using config method.
This config method requires
four arguments.
The first argument
is MediaFormat.
So MediaFormat, usually you can
get the return value from
your MediaExtractor.
So let me go back a few slides,
just to show you.
See for example, the
getTrackFormat returns you the
MediaFormat objects.
So you can just pass that
MediaFormat object to the
config method.
So if it's a video track, if you
decide to render the video
to a surface, you
pass the second
argument, the surface argument.
If your data source is
encrypted, and then you need
to provide a MediaCrypto
object.
The last flags indicate to the
API whether this is an encoder
or decoder instance.
So why you need that is because
if they the instance
is created by the third create
by codec name, you are not
able to tell whether this is
for encoding or decoding.
So that's why you need a flag to
tell, so this config is for
decoding purpose, or for
encoding purpose.
The next set of API basically
is a standard set of media
control, like, you can
do start, stop.
You can do flash, I have a
list of flash [? gear. ?]
I will escape those APIs,
basically just standard
MediaControl API.
In a core of MediaCodec API,
it's basically how we pass
data back and the forth between
the media process and
the application process and
the media server process.
We are using array of byte
buffers for this purpose.
There are two arrays of
byte buffers, one
used for the input.
The second one is
use for output.
The actual communication between
your application
process and the media server
process actually is not
bypassing the byte
buffers directly.
Instead, it is passing the index
into the array, rather
than just pass the byte
buffer directly.
So the next set of APIs
basically tells you how to use
these buffers.
So for input, you have
three methods.
The first one is to
getInputBuffers.
You only can call this message
after you start, after you
call start.
So this method will tell you the
array of byte buffers used
for this codec session, either
an encoding session, or a
decoding session.
Once you know the array of byte
buffers, and then you can
find out whether there are any
input buffers available for
you to use by calling
dequeueInputBuffer.
This dequeueInputBuffer take
an argument with timeout.
So if you give a timeout value
negative value, basically you
just wait forever until an input
buffer is available.
Otherwise, you just wait for the
specified timeout period.
And if there is no buffer
available, it will return a
negative integer to indicate
it's timeout, and there is no
input buffer available.
So if there is an available
input buffer before the
timeout period, then it will
return a valid byte array
index, which basically
is a nonactive value.
So using this index, and then
you can find out the right
byte buffer using the input
array of byte buffers.
So once you will find out the
right buffer to use, and then
you can put valid input data
inside this byte buffer.
So you can either do some image
processing before you
put your data in, that's fine.
It's up to you.
But after you prepare your data
and to put it into the
byte buffer, you can use the
next method, queueInputBuffer,
to send this input buffer
to the codec.
So this queueInputBuffer takes
a bunch of arguments.
Those are pretty obvious.
But I want to talk about
the first argument.
As you can see, it is index.
It is not the byte buffer.
So you need to pass a
valid index to this
queueInputBuffer, which usually
you got from the
return value of
dequeueInputBuffer.
The next argument, basically, is
offset, basically indicate
the starting position
of your valid data
inside that byte buffer.
And size basically a number bias
of valid data you put in
your byte buffer.
The ctsTimeUs argument basically
tells you what is
the presentation time for this
input buffer, and the flags,
basically, a bunch of associated
flags associated
with this byte buffer--
like, whether this is a key
frame, something like that.
So similarly for output buffer,
you can find out the
array byte buffers by call
getOutputBuffers.
Similarly, we are not using
the byte buffer directly
between your application and
media server process.
We are passing index of the
output byte buffer.
So in order to find out whether
an output buffer is
available, you'll call
dequeueOutputBuffer.
The resume value will indicate
whether you get a
valid output buffer.
If it is a negative value,
there are three cases.
It can be a timeout,
so indicate there
was no buffer available.
It can indicate something like
the output format changed.
For decoding applications,
usually it happens.
So you start to decode,
and you find out the
output buffer changed.
So an active return value from
dequeueOutputBuffer will tell
you the output buffer
format changed,
output format changed.
The third negative value
can return from
dequeueOutputBuffer is an
indication of output buffer
itself changed.
So after you receive that return
value, you need to call
getOutputBuffer method again to
get a refresh on the array
of output buffers.
If dequeueOutputBuffer return
a nonactive value, meaning a
valid buffer index, then you
can use that for the
subsequent call,
releaseOutputBuffer.
So before you call
releaseOutputBuffer, you may
also do some image processing
on the buffer, and using the
valid index to find out the
correct byte buffer
that hold the data.
And then you can do some image
processing with that data.
And then you call this
releaseOutputBuffer.
ReleaseOutputBuffer, basically,
there are two arguments.
The first one, same thing,
is index into the
array of byte buffers.
The second is a Boolean value.
Basically, indicate whether you
want to do rendering for
this output buffer.
For video, rendering means you
want to show the video frame.
For audio, many of you probably
want to send it to
audio sync for decoding
purpose.
So for each byte buffer,
regardless whether it's input
or output, we provide you
a set of metadata
associated with it.
If you look at the
dequeueOutputBuffer, the first
argument is BufferInfo.
The BufferInfo object tells you
the metadata associated
with a byte buffer.
So you can find out information
like what's the
number bias that this buffer
holds the valid data.
And what are the starting
position, like the valid data
begin inside this byte buffer.
What is the presentation time
for this data inside the byte
buffer, and also the flags,
such as whether this byte
buffer holds a sync frame data,
or whether this hold the
decoder specific information
or codec config flag, or
whether this actually indicate
is end of stream sample.
So to show you how to
use the MediaCodec
API, have two sides.
The first slide basically shows
you a typical use of the
low-level MediaCodec APIs.
So you'll start off by creating
a MediaCodec instance
by calling one of the three
create methods.
So in this particular case, you
create a decoding instance
using the supported MIME type.
And then, you need to configure
this codec by
calling config method.
So the config method, basically,
it needs to know
the format that this
codec deal with.
That format can come from your
MediaExtractor, if you provide
a customized MediaExtractor
implementation, or you use the
MediaExtractor class we provided
for you, and by
calling getTrackFormat.
So that returns the right format
for you, so that your
codec can deal with that
specific media track.
So once this MediaCodec is
configured, you can just start
decoding process by
calling start.
After you call in start, then it
is time to get the array of
input byte buffers, and an
array of output buffers.
And you can also find out
the output format
for this media track.
Then, follow that.
Basically, it's an iterative
process.
Basically, you just send input
data to the codec to do the
coding or encoding, and then
you get output from the
decoder or encoder.
So that's an iterative process
in the follow up as I've shown
on the slide.
So after you are done with this
process, you stop the
decoding process, and then you
release all the resources
associated with this
MediaCodec.
Let me go to the next slide to
show you how to actually send
input data to the decoder for
decoding, and how do to get
output data from the decoder.
So this slide shows
you the details.
The first part shows you how
to send encode data to the
decoder instance.
So firstly, you call
codec.dequeueInputBuffer.
You check its return value.
If its return value is
nonactive, meaning greater
than or equal to zero, then it
is a valid buffer index,
meaning there is
an input buffer
available for you to use.
So at this point, you know which
buffer is available by
using the index, which you can
find out along with the array
of input buffers.
And you can do image processing
on the input buffer.
And once you're done with your
image processing, you can call
queueInputBuffer with the
right buffer index.
And then, that API will send
the input buffer to the
decoding instance
for decoding.
If the return is inactive,
that means it probably is
timeout, so you need to retry.
Next, I'll show you how to get
the output from the decoder.
So you call
codec.dequeueOutputBuffer with a timeout.
Same thing it returns you
an integer value.
If it is a nonactive value--
meaning, you find, basically,
there is an output buffer
available, meaning the
decoder already
generate an output data.
And it's already stored in one
of the output buffers.
So how to find out that byte
buffer, you use the return
value from dequeueOutputBuffer,
use that
as an index into the array
output byte buffers.
And of course, you can also
decide to do some image
processing with it.
It's up to you.
After you're done with it, and
then you can release this
output buffer back to the output
buffer array pool.
If the return value from
dequeueOutputBuffer is
negative, there are three
cases I mentioned.
The slides only show
two cases.
So the first case is timeout.
Basically, you can check
whether it's timeout.
If it's timeout, you can retry
until you find an output
buffer available.
Otherwise, if the
return value of
INFO_OUTPUT_BUFFERS_CHANGED.
That means, the buffer
size or number of
buffers may have changed.
So you need to get a refresh on
the array of byte buffers
for output.
So you'll call
getOutputBuffers for that purpose.
For the third case, if
the return value is
INFO_OUTPUT_FORMAT_CHANGED, that
means the decoder will
find out the codec format
basically changed, or the
subsequent sample output will
conform to the new format.
So in order to find out the new
output format, you can use
getOutputFormat for
that purpose.
So to wrap up the API for
MediaCodec, I want to mention
a couple things more.
First, although the example
is given using a decoding
instance, most of the APIs
in this MediaCodec class
basically is the same for
encoding instance and decode
instance, so that you do not
need to learn two sets of
different APIs.
Second thing I want to point
out is if you're using
MediaCodec API, it is up to
the application to do the
audio and video synchronization
because we
return the buffer to tell you
what's the presentation time.
Now, the application has the
information to do proper audio
and video synchronization.
Well, with the release of this
low-level MediaCodec API, now
it is up to you to write more
sophisticated media
applications to your
imagination.
Before I want to open the floor
for questions from the
audience, I want to thanks
Andreas, in particular, for
developing the low-level media
APIs for Jellybean release.
Also, I want to point out, if
you want to find out more
information about OpenMAX spec,
you can use that URL on
the Q&A slide.
Now, let me open floor for
questions from the audience.
If there is any questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for the
presentation.
So I have two questions.
One is, is the actual decoding
and encoding happening inside
of the media server
process still?
JAMES DONG: Yes, that's true.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And so in terms of battery
consumption, if you were to
write a media player application
using these APIs,
versus a natively written one,
how will they compare?
JAMES DONG: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
So we did some experiment,
although our test app is not
instrumented.
And basically, the usual
findings using the MediaCodec
API, we find out the total
[INAUDIBLE] consumption for
the application, basically, is
roughly 10 to 20 medians above
what do we have using
media player class.
So a little bit more.
But I think it's acceptable.
AUDIENCE: Thanks you.
JAMES DONG: Sure, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the presentation.
I have a question about this
low-level codec APIs.
So does that mean that I can
write applications to do the
real-time video chat
with those APIs?
My understanding is that those
codec will enable leveraging
the hardware capabilities
through
OpenMAX protocol, right?
JAMES DONG: That's true.
The MediaCodec API actually
allows you to access the
low-level decoding/encoding
capabilities, regardless
whether the decoder is a
software decoder or is a
hardware decoder, or regardless
whether encoder is
a software encoder or hardware
accelerated encoder.
So you can leverage the
hardware accelerated
MediaCodec.
AUDIENCE: And my understanding
is that prior to the
Jellybean, those are
not exposed, right?
At least for encoding for
the hardware capability?
JAMES DONG: That's true.
That's why I said, this is a
new set of low-level media
APIs only available in
Jellybean, and after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you for the answer.
JAMES DONG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
One, is there an x264
hardware-based encoder that
goes with the 4.1 that is
accessible through the
low-level APIs?
JAMES DONG: To answer
your question, yes.
For example, the current
device, for example,
[INAUDIBLE]
and [? Prime ?] all provide you
the hardware accelerated
AVC decoder, which are able to
decode AVC high profile level
for videos.
So really, it depends on
the device capability.
So if you have a low end device,
you may not be able to
have the hardware to do that.
So that's why you need
that capability query
APIs to find out.
AUDIENCE: And my second
question, is there an RTSP
streaming component that could
integrate with the encoders
that work with the the
new media APIs?
JAMES DONG: RTSP streaming--
AUDIENCE: Server.
JAMES DONG: Server.
Yeah, server we do not have.
We have a client
implementation.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
JAMES DONG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
First of all, with the release
of Jellybean, are you adding
any extra codecs that kind of
implement these APIs that
would serve as good examples?
JAMES DONG: Your question
basically asks whether we have
additional Media Codecs
to support the--
AUDIENCE: That were added
in Jellybean versus ICS?
JAMES DONG: Added
in Jellybean.
Well, this really depends
on the device you have.
But the commonly available
codecs are basically for
video, you have AVC decoder, AVC
encoder, you have impact
for video encoder/decoder, you
have H.263 encoder/decoder.
You would expect it
to have a commonly
available Android device.
For audio, you have a bunch
of format to support
a decoder for MP3.
For encoder, you have AAC,
AMR Narrowband/Wideband.
So all of those are supported.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Second, you kind of mentioned
the MediaCrypto, I believe it
was, for the actual DRM, I
would assume, production.
Can you go into a little more
detail on what would be
involved in using that
in your app?
JAMES DONG: Yeah.
That, unfortunately, is out
of the scope of this
presentation, which is
another talk itself.
But basically, we publish
a new API, called
a MediaCrypto class.
You can do decoding of
encrypted content.
So currently, we implemented
this and verified with
Widevine DRM, Widevine
encrypted content.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAMES DONG: Does that answer
your question?
Yeah, otherwise, like I say,
is another long talk,
basically, about MediaCrypto
API.
So once the API is public,
you can look at it.
It's pretty simple also.
AUDIENCE: The API's
are going to be--
JAMES DONG: For MediaCrypto.
AUDIENCE: When is the actual
documentation of that going to
be totally available?
JAMES DONG: It's going to
be released with SDK.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thanks.
JAMES DONG: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
in the configuration
that it uses a surface.
What does it use that
for, that value?
JAMES DONG: OK.
The second argument for
configure method is surface.
So if you want to render your
video output, for example,
then you want to pass a surface,
so that it can render
that video output.
That's for that purpose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And how does that work with
the syncing of the audio?
Would you render the movie, and
then have another thread
that's parsing your audio?
JAMES DONG: Yeah, it's up to
the application, basically.
You probably need to write
a multiple threads.
One thread is handling
the video.
The other thread is handling
the audio.
But it's up to the application
to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you
just passed the
surface for us to use?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
We just passed the surface
as the video sync.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
JAMES DONG: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In Ice Cream Sandwich, you
released a new low-level
streaming API.
Will Jellybean build upon,
or replace that one?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, let
me turn this one off.
Sorry, what was your
question again?
AUDIENCE: In Ice Cream Sandwich,
you released the new
OpenMAX AL streaming
low-level library.
Will Jellybean replace
or build upon that?
JAMES DONG: Well, it's used for
different purpose, basically.
It's used for a different
purpose.
And I think from Jellybean and
on, we should focus on
MediaCodec API.
AUDIENCE: Will the ICS one
still be supported then?
JAMES DONG: It will be
still supported.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then, you mentioned
MediaCrypto.
Is there a way to protect the
decrypted yet still encoded
data using MediaCrypto?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
For encrypted counting actually,
you are not able to
do actually access the
output byte buffer.
So it's opaque data,
basically, to
the application process.
So if you have hardware assisted
protection for your
video path, then the
output buffer
actually is hardware protected.
AUDIENCE: Does it just
support Widevine?
Or do custom DRMs support
it, too, then?
JAMES DONG: Currently, we
only have verified the
implementation with Widevine.
But I can imagine you're
also able to
work with other schemes.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
JAMES DONG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My first question is,
is there any constraint
for threading access
of these buffers?
Say, usually we use different
thread for correct data, and
then maybe another
to call a codec.
So is there any constraint on
thread part for accessing the
input buffer or output buffer?
JAMES DONG: Sorry,
can you rephrase?
AUDIENCE: Oh, and then
make it simple.
When I access the input buffer
and output buffer, can I use
[INAUDIBLE]
thread?
Is there any constraint
for it?
JAMES DONG: No, there
shouldn't be.
As long as you have a valid
input buffer or output buffer,
you can use it for
your own purpose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My second question is,
you mentioned about
the extractor decoder.
Is there any way to get to the
hardware color conversion,
like YUV to RGB?
JAMES DONG: No.
There is no API we're published
in Jellybean for
that purpose, for color
conversion.
AUDIENCE: And you mentioned the
codec information can tell
profile and the level
supported.
And is there any way to know
the profile or level of the
media source?
JAMES DONG: The profile and
the levels for the media
source, no.
Currently, we are not
supporting that.
So as an application developer,
you need to know
the source, basically.
AUDIENCE: Maybe not.
JAMES DONG: If you do not,
then the codec API will
indicate it's not able to handle
if the codec is not
available to handle.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read the document.
Is there any [INAUDIBLE]
callback since?
JAMES DONG: Well, for example,
the setDataSource and
getTrackCount, you may not get
right number if the file
format is not supported,
for example.
AUDIENCE: Say for the audio is
supported, the video is not
supported, so maybe check a
count where there will be one
instead of two?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And my last minor question is,
in your code showing on the
screen, you used two equal to
compare the codec MIME type.
Is it safe?
JAMES DONG: Two equal, sorry?
AUDIENCE: Two equal signal.
Instead of caller stream
equals two.
JAMES DONG: Oh Yeah, that's
probably my--
Yeah, but basically just compel
the MIME type against
the supported MIME type.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
JAMES DONG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You haven't mentioned the
Android indicator.
So are the same set of API
changes also available on the
native side, like from
the NDK side?
JAMES DONG: No.
AUDIENCE: No?
JAMES DONG: This is
all Java API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And have there been any changes
to NDK exposed APIs at
all for Jellybean?
JAMES DONG: Not as
far as I know.
These are just Java APIs,
not related to NDK.
AUDIENCE: From the looks of your
sample code, it's really
just a thin wrapper around
some native code?
Like, most of the codes.
JAMES DONG: Yes, those will be
available at the native layer,
but it's not part of NDK.
AUDIENCE: So you cannot actually
call these from--
JAMES DONG: No, we do not
recommend you to call directly
into the native code.
AUDIENCE: Because some audio
APIs are actually
exposed in the NDK?
JAMES DONG: Yeah, if it is
exposed in the NDK, you have
the guarantee, like
we intended.
But if it's not a part of the
NDK, then we may change it.
AUDIENCE: If you want to write
some really low latency code,
for example, and like you're
calling native code anyway.
So it kind of makes sense
to actually expose
these codecs natively.
JAMES DONG: But for Jellybean
release, we are
not exposing that.
AUDIENCE: OK, Thank you.
JAMES DONG: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned about we need
to do the YUV to RGB
conversion.
So can the surface be backward
surface texture?
In that case, will we get
something as a YUV texture,
and we can use [INAUDIBLE]
to do the color conversion?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, I haven't
mentioned that.
But it's up to you to do
the image processing.
It's not necessary you
do color conversion.
OK, so the media API basically
gives you the raw data, like
the output of uncompressed
video frame, for example.
You can do image processing
on it and--
AUDIENCE: It is in what format?
Is it RGB?
JAMES DONG: Well, the formatter
will tell you
basically, you can call
getOutputFormat.
You can find out what's
the format there.
AUDIENCE: And it is expected
to be in an RGB format, and
not an intermediate
YUV format, is it?
JAMES DONG: No, it's
a decoder output.
So mostly, it is YUV
output format.
AUDIENCE: So that means we need
to the color conversion.
JAMES DONG: Well, it depends
on how you do your image
processing, yes.
AUDIENCE: So if you don't image
processing, and will
just say boolean render to be
true, the underlying platform
will do the color conversion and
render it to the surface?
JAMES DONG: Yes.
JAMES DONG: And are these
buffers getting
copied in any way?
Like, the decoder could use the
decoder resources to push
the decoded buffers.
Is it getting copied from the
GPU memory to CPU memory?
JAMES DONG: Well, we try to
avoid [INAUDIBLE] copies as
much as we can.
And as far as a node, there
is no copy at all
at the media level.
And the only traffic
communication it added for
this media API is the indices
of these input buffer and
output buffer arrays.
Basically, that's the added
communication traffic between
the application and the
media server process.
AUDIENCE: But then, if the
decoder is using GPU memory,
and if it has to be passed as
a [INAUDIBLE] into Java,
wouldn't it have to be a
non-GPU memory for the
application to do any kind
of post-processing?
JAMES DONG: Well, the byte
buffer array is basically just
a wrap around of the
native buffers.
It may not necessarily say a
specific format for that.
AUDIENCE: So it could
be textures, too?
JAMES DONG: It could be.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And how do we know if it's
a texture or not?
JAMES DONG: You don't
know at this point.
There is no API that
tells you about it.
AUDIENCE: But if you have to
post-processing, we should
know the [INAUDIBLE]
inside the byte buffer in order
to read those datas?
JAMES DONG: Well, the data
itself, actually, is arranged
in a way that you
can access it.
That's basically, find out the
output, the YUV format, and
the size of it.
AUDIENCE: I see.
And the encoded data is passed
as like elementary streams?
JAMES DONG: Sorry, I think we
are running out of time.
And we can take this offline.
All right?
OK.
Thank you.